[Music]
in our school matters series we're
looking at the important role
historically black colleges and
universities have played in america's
education system
oprah winfrey spike lee and vice
president-elect kamala harris are all
graduates of these institutions the
majority of hbcus were founded
after the civil war to provide higher
education for african americans
most u.s schools continue to prohibit
black people from attending
for a century after slavery was
abolished
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller shows us why many hbcus
are seeing increases in enrollment but
still facing
big funding challenges
at the heart of historically black
colleges is the black experience
[Music]
so why howard we had a collective
understanding that
we come from different places but we
have this
collective unity but beyond culture is
curriculum
what have you seen fists provide you
that you don't think you would have
gotten at a
pwi a predominantly white institution
learning about my history learning about
where we come from
before slavery i think it's something
that needs to be discussed because
in regular school we don't learn that
that's not a
part of the curriculum since 1867 howard
university in washington d.c has awarded
more than a hundred thousand degrees
and ranks among the highest producers of
the nation's black professionals
howard university president wayne
frederick md
over the past 50 years the number one
producer of african americans who went
to harvard's mba program was harvard
undergrad and number two was howard what
have hbcus produced
80 percent of the nation's black judges
50 percent of its black
doctors and now while i may be the first
woman
in this office i will not be the last
the first woman who happens to be black
elected vice president of the united
states
there were once about 400 historically
black institutions or hbcus
there are about a hundred left and they
were the ones that survived and
made it through all the tough times van
newkirk is the interim president of the
historically black
fisk university in nashville tennessee
founded
in 1866. we turn out folks like w.b du
bois ida wales
john hope franklin john lewis we have a
history of
turning out folks who are endued and
with social justice about
one-third of hbcus have experienced
record increases in applications
and enrollment over the past three years
according to the center for minority
serving institutions
why do you think we're seeing
record-breaking enrollment
when we look at what's going on in the
nation right now issues around social
justice
and racism
[Applause]
i see students coming back to hbcus
coming home
want to make sure that we move more into
the mainstream and we become a
university that
is sustainable that sustainability
becomes even more challenging with
students in need
according to the american council on
education
over 70 percent of hbcu students have
limited finances
why have so many of the hbcus
struggled financially well for two
reasons one
uh the black community is one of the
poorest communities in america
and and frankly because philanthropy
michael lomax of the united negro
college fund says
hbcus have rarely gotten large donations
resulting in endowments that are about
70 percent smaller than
other schools but 2020 ushered in the
biggest donations in
hbcu history 120 million from netflix
ceo
reed hastings and half a billion from
mackenzie scott
the ex-wife of jeff bezos these big
gifts mean
that american philanthropy is beginning
to see
that equity and equality mean equitable
giving
as well students tell me you can't put a
price tag on what they gain
at hbcus i feel like i'm
getting a foundation to help
develop the framework of how i'm going
to live the rest of my life
fears gave me confidence i could be
myself in
every arena you know and i didn't have
to change who i was
for cbs this morning hbcu grad
and howard university alum michelle
miller
michelle listen we are we are a better
country because
hbcus exist yeah i mean to hear that
stat there 80
of the nation's black judges 50 of its
black
doctors but then you look at the
endowments that's huge right that we
you know you don't have the same support
financially and that's why that money
needs to keep flowing to those